y
[Música]
austria volverá al confinamiento total a
partir del próximo lunes y durante 20
días esto por el aumento de contagios de
kobe 19 además a partir de febrero del
2022 todos los residentes del país
tendrán que vacunarse obligatoriamente
es la primera nación europea en aprobar
esta medida por otra parte la situación
sanitaria se degrada en alemania
tendremos análisis las autoridades
sanitarias de eeuu aprobaron la dosis de
refuerzo para todos los mayores de 18
años ahora sólo falta que los centros
para el control y la prevención de
enfermedades
revisen hoy la reglamentación al
respecto las vacunas contra el cob y 19
adicionales serán de facer y modernas
la onu pide pruebas de que la tenista
china peng shuai está viva la deportista
desapareció luego de denunciar que un ex
alto funcionario del gobierno chino
abusó sexualmente de ella la asociación
de tenis femenino está dispuesta a
retirar sus torneos del país
[Música]
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y estaré
con ustedes en este recorrido y
comenzamos en austria porque el país
vuelve al confinamiento a partir del
próximo lunes todos los ciudadanos deben
guardarse en sus casas por un periodo de
20 días además impusieron que la
vacunación sea obligatoria a partir de
febrero es el primer país europeo en
aprobar la obligatoriedad de las vacunas
todas las medidas son porque la tasa de
contagios se encuentra entre las más
altas del continente con casi 1000 casos
por cada 100.000 habitantes en la última
semana alemania por su parte también
está rompiendo sus propios récords de
contagios y ante esto los líderes
regionales acordaron restricciones
contra quienes no están vacunados y
habitan en zonas de alta hospitalización
ya varias regiones han anunciado la
cancelación de los mercados navideños
para analizar la situación en europa
conectamos al estado ahora con gina
también y ella es representante de la
ops/oms en colombia bienvenida a
france24 señora también y es un gusto
tenerla porque se están disparando los
contagios nuevamente en europa y esta
situación pone en duda la efectividad de
las vacunas o no
no las vacunas son seguras las cunas son
efectivas recordemos que este virus
sigue circulando en los países del mundo
y también acá en la región de las
américas y todavía hay un porcentaje
importante de personas que somos
susceptibles a este virus y a pesar de
que estemos vacunados que tengamos las
dos dosis según la vacuna de laboratorio
que el cual hemos recibido la dosis pues
hay un porcentaje de personas que
podemos estar expuestos y que podemos
adquirir la infección por el sarc o tos
o una de sus variantes en las vacunas
son seguras y efectivas y sobre todo lo
que evitan esa enfermedad severa
mortalidad y esos casos severos que
llevan a la muerte entonces si tenemos
que vacunarnos pero hay que mantener las
medidas de protección personal y
distanciamiento eso es lo que se hay un
relajamiento a nivel de muchos países y
es lo que está ocurriendo y también
falta un porcentaje importante de
personas todavía por vacunarse
tenemos que vacunarnos y mantener las
medidas de bioseguridad pero además en
europa comienzan de nuevo los
confinamientos y empiezan las vacunas
obligatorias como lo estábamos hablando
en austria y en la pandemia hemos visto
que lo que pasa en ese continente
termina por replicarse tarde o temprano
en américa latina' usted cree que iremos
a un escenario similar y es posible
replicar medidas de vacunación
obligatoria en américa latina'
todos los países estamos expuestos a
este contar con dos o sus variantes y
como estamos viendo la variante delta es
la que está predominando en la gran
mayoría de países en el mundo y esta es
una variante que es más transmisible por
eso también nuevamente la vacunación es
importante las medidas de protección
personal el uso de mascarilla ese
distanciamiento de dos metros el lavado
frecuente de manos no estar en
aglomeraciones evitar lugares donde no
hay una ventilación eso es importante
todas esas medidas las tendremos que
hacer en forma conjunta y la detección
de casos y contactos o lo que es la
vigilancia epidemiológica para cuando en
un caso es positivo guarde aislamiento
sus contactos cuarentena y puedan
cortarse cadenas de transmisión si los
países de nuestra región de las américas
están también expuestos ya vemos una
tendencia de crecimiento en las últimas
semanas sobre todo si comparamos a la
última semana o incremento del 8% en los
casos reportados en los países de las
américas y eso nos da un signo de alarma
de aldea necesitamos reforzar esas
medidas de protección personal y
distanciamiento cada país con su
autoridad sanitaria y los ministerios de
salud pues evalúan los indicadores
estratégicos los indicadores de la
epidemiología y para poder tomar las
medidas que sean necesarios y también le
quiero hacer una pregunta sobre eeuu
pero antes dar un breve contexto de qué
está pasando en este país porque la
autoridad reguladora aprobó la dosis de
refuerzo para todos los mayores de 18
años esto es un intento por frenar los
contagios con la llegada de las
vacaciones de navidad las farmacéuticas
pfizer y modernas anunciaron la decisión
de la fed de aplicar una dosis adicional
seis meses después de la última ahora
los centros para el control de
enfermedades tendrán que apoyar la
iniciativa de vacunación incluso para
los jóvenes para que los jóvenes gocen
de buena salud en eeuu es uno de los
países más afectados por el virus y al
menos el 60 por ciento de la población
ya está totalmente vacunada señora
también en este sentido las terceras
dosis complican más la escasez de
vacunas contra el cob y 19 en
continentes enteros como áfrica y como
ya lo ha advertido la ms cuál es el
impacto de ese refuerzo de dosis en eeuu
y también cómo esto afecta al mundo
entero
la organización mundial de la salud en
voz de nuestro director el doctor pedro
hace un llamado a la solidaridad de
todos los países tenemos que hacer ese
esfuerzo de proteger primero las
poblaciones más vulnerables a los
mayores de 60 a los adultos con
comorbilidades al personal de salud y
puede y puede que todavía hay país hay
hay todavía países sobre todo en áfrica
como mencionaba que no han logrado
siquiera la meta del 10 por ciento que
fue trazada para septiembre tenemos
también la meta de por lo menos el 40
por ciento de la población puede ser
vacunados al final de este año y en
junio el 70 por ciento entonces ahí es
el llamado a todos los países si ya han
logrado proteger a su población más
vulnerable pues también compartir
compartir esas voces que tienen con los
países que todavía están esperando poder
tener acceso a las vacunas contra la cob
y 19 podemos darles cifras en relación a
esta meta sólo un país
perdón un país de ingreso bajo no ha
logrado la meta del 10 por ciento son 38
países de ingreso medio de que logran si
la meta del 10 por ciento y en relación
a la meta del 40 por ciento para este
año todavía no hay ningún país de
ingreso bajo que haya logrado esta meta
del 40 por ciento sino también y muchas
gracias por este panorama y por sus
recomendaciones de vacunarnos y
continuar con las medidas de protección
y siguiendo en eeuu hoy la cámara de
representantes aprobó el plan de gasto
social de la presidencia de joe biden el
proyecto pasó con 220 votos a favor y
213 en contra lo que demuestra que
incluso en la cámara baja donde el
oficialismo tiene más amplia mayoría el
plan general tiene fuertes divisiones
ahora falta que el senado lo discuta y
vote al respecto si lo aprueba esto
inyectaría
175 billones de dólares a sectores como
la atención médica la energía y la lucha
contra el cambio climático además sería
una gran victoria para joe biden quien
hoy mismo calificó el voto de la cámara
un paso gigantesco
en noticias de latinoamericana cerraron
las campañas en chile y avanza el
periodo de reflexión previo a las
elecciones de este domingo 21 de
noviembre en este país además de elegir
presidente
los chilenos renovarán el parlamento y
votarán por 27 de los 43 senadores a
propósito de la cita electoral les
presentamos una serie de informes
especiales de france 24 los dos
favoritos a suceder a sebastián piñera
son gabriel boric y jose antonio kast
veamos a continuación quienes son estos
candidatos
de los siete aspirantes al sillón
presidencial en chile 2 se perfilan para
la segunda vuelta según los sondeos
aunque no aciertan desde 2019 el
izquierdista gabriel boric del frente
amplio y el ultraderechista josé antonio
kast del partido republicano por primera
vez en la historia de la democracia
chilena ninguno de los dos favoritos
forma parte de las dos coaliciones
tradicionales de centroizquierda y
centroderecha que durante más de tres
décadas se repartieron el poder hay una
posición entre una cierta creo yo en
libertad de los votantes
para elegir opciones que están fuera
quizás de lo comúnmente tomarían por
razones más más identitaria y también
creo yo que hay una especie de
muchos votantes que se sienten huérfanos
en el sentido que la que no hay que las
alternativas por la que tradicionalmente
votaban ya no son alternativas viables
el estadio social de 2019 que dio inicio
a las peores protestas desde la
dictadura marcó un momento clave en el
país sudamericano también la presunta
implicación del actual presidente de
chile sebastián piñera en los papeles de
pandora ha generado aún más desconfianza
hacia los típicos partidos aunque piñera
asegura que las acusaciones son falsas
ayer el senado rechazó una acusación
constitucional
basada en hechos falsos
suposiciones o meras conjeturas y sin
ningún fundamento
quiero reconocer la actitud de los
diputados y senadores que actuaron con
seriedad y responsabilidad
es la primera vez en 16 años que ni
piñera ni michelle bachelet gobernará en
el país el 21 de noviembre casi 15
millones de chilenos votarán en la
primera vuelta por su candidato de
preferencia la segunda vuelta se
llevaría a cabo el 19 de diciembre
la deforestación en la amazonía
brasileña aumentó a niveles que no se
veían desde hace 15 años el instituto
nacional de investigaciones espaciales
de brasil el inpe publicó los resultados
de su sistema de monitoreo y comprobó
que en los últimos 12 meses se
deforestaron más de 13 mil kilómetros
cuadrados de selva tropical esto es como
si se talarán más de la mitad de todo el
país del salvador el repunte de la
deforestación llega en medio de las
promesas del presidente ya ir bolsonaro
de proteger a la amazonía aunque
paralelamente ha impulsado proyectos de
agricultura en territorios indígenas en
esa zona
y la otan seguirá respaldando a sus
aliados en la crisis migratoria de
belarús polonia lituania y letonia así
lo dijo el secretario general jens
stoltenberg tras reunirse en berlín con
la saliente canciller alemana angela
merkel la otan afirmó que rusia tiene
una actitud cínica por su posible
respaldo a los vuelos rusos para llevar
migrantes a la frontera sus palabras se
registran cuando la guardia de fronteras
de polonia informó este viernes de 255
nuevos intentos de cruzar hacia
territorio de la unión europea y reportó
la expulsión de 45 extranjeros ucrania
por su parte anunció que planea
construir una barrera en la frontera de
2.500 kilómetros en sus pasos con
belarús y rusia el próximo año
y la tenista china peng shuai ex número
uno del mundo en dobles sigue
desaparecida mientras las redes sociales
se llenan con el hashtag donde está
pensó hay este viernes la onu le reclamó
a china que investigue el caso y pidió
pruebas de supervivencia desde el país
asiático no dan noticias del paradero de
la deportista y tampoco responden
concretamente a las acusaciones de que
un ex alto funcionario del gobierno
chino obligó a peng shuai a tener
relaciones sexuales con él les contamos
más en el reporte de rodrigo se dan
dónde está pensó hay es el hashtag que
se ha lanzado en redes sociales para
reclamar a china noticias sobre el
paradero de la estrella del tenis este
viernes la propia onu se ha pronunciado
sobre el caso
y sin punto queremos subrayar que es
importante saber dónde está y ya saben
su estado es saber sobre su bienestar y
como he dicho creemos que sería
importante que se investigarán sus
acusaciones de agresión sexual contra el
ex viceprimer ministro de china zhang
weixing en su fans a miriam ayón soul y
el pasado 2 de noviembre la ex número
uno del mundo de dobles hizo dichas
acusaciones en su cuenta de la red
social china weibo desde entonces se
encuentra en paradero desconocido pese a
una supuesta carta suya que lo niega el
escrito fue publicado por la televisión
estatal 'china cgt en la w tea el máximo
organismo del tenis femenino duda de su
autenticidad
la w tea y el resto del mundo necesitan
pruebas independientes y verificables de
que está a salvo e intentado en vano
contactar la en varias ocasiones y por
varias vías peng shuai debe poder hablar
sin coerción o intimidación de ninguna
fuente
preguntado este viernes sobre la
cuestión el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores chino ha rehusado a hablar
sobre el tema de pulso airways en ti no
es un asunto diplomático y no tengo
conocimiento de ello en de tsinghua la
realidad es que este escándalo se une a
los que si tuvo que responder por
acusaciones de genocidio en la provincia
de xinjiang antes de los juegos
olímpicos de invierno de 2022
y terminamos con una luna roja anoche y
en la madrugada de este viernes el
fenómeno astronómico se pudo ver en el
cielo de casi toda américa latina' de
norteamérica y de varios países en asia
y europa la luna se vio roja porque tuvo
más del 97 por ciento de su superficie
cubierta por la sombra de la tierra este
fue el último eclipse lunar del año y
además es el más largo de todo el siglo
el fenómeno duró más de tres horas según
la nasa aquí los dejamos con algunas de
las mejores imágenes que dejó esta luna
rojiza
[Música]